[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's seven o'clock this is a sky news
question and answer special on the war
in ukraine all through the day we've
been gathering your questions and we'll
be doing our very best to answer them in
the next hour but first the headlines
curfew in kiev the mayor restricts
movement around the city as he prepares
for difficult moments ahead
everyone is angry i talk to the people
they don't want to leave
the russian journalists who disrupted
primetime television news to speak out
against the war appears in court boris
johnson defends his trip to saudi arabia
and says western nations must not be
hooked on russian oil and gas
vladimir putin over the last
years has been like a pusher
feeding an addiction
in western countries to his hydrocarbons
the uk sanctions hundreds more wealthy
russians including the former president
dmitry medvedev
[Music]
good evening welcome to a sky news
question and answer special on the war
in ukraine coming up the military expert
and former director general of the royal
united services institute professor
michael clark will be here throughout
the next hour to answer your questions
on the conflict but first the mayor of
kiev has told sky news that the capital
is the heart of ukraine and will be
defended in its darkest hours vitaly
klitschko has warned that the next few
days will be a test for the city's
defenses and has imposed a 35-hour long
curfew from tonight until thursday five
people were killed in russian attacks in
residential areas this morning sky
special correspondent alex crawford
reports now from kiev
this was another step up in attacks
inside the capital
more homes hit more lives lost they've
been so resilient
but this is really taking a toll
tears yes but a steely toughness too
we'll keep ourselves together he says
tears on his cheeks we will remain
strong
the city was roused early again with
multiple strikes in all points around
the capital and they're expecting a lot
more over the next few days
the sound of battle is unavoidable now
in the capital but this army chaplain
called it an unequal fight
this isn't war he says this is
international terrorism war is armies
against armies but when armies attack
civilians this is international
terrorism
the mayor called it a dangerous moment
and immediately slapped a 35-hour curfew
on the capitol
how would you describe the spirit of the
ukrainian people and your feeling about
this
the spirit right now everyone is angry i
talk to the people they don't want to
live
in this activity
bring much more
energy to everyone and everyone
understand don't want to live want to
defend defend our city
they are meeting this onslaught with
fortitude cleaning out their broken
homes and just getting on with it
some have sent their families and
children outside kiev because they've
known the russian military was homing in
on this city
oh these are all the children's toys
yeah
the children things all
but the war has reached right into their
living rooms and balconies now
my parents still in the kiev
living on left bank of
[Music]
my sister too
but we've
still there
you're still here yeah
and
i'm not afraid
because i know it's
i believe our victory
the residents know their homes and their
lives are collateral damage in the
battle for this the prize their capital
city but they're not bowed
i don't think i am brave but
i don't want to leave my city i don't
want to leave my country and uh
if it will need be i will take a
shoot to take a gun and
go
go to fight and
kill russia
the capital's mayor expects more of this
and has warned that russian activity is
expected to substantially increase over
the next 48 hours and he's urged his
fellow residents to be wary
he and his brother believe the russian
military is very close right now and
they've no intention of going anywhere
you can throw a stone
and he's a russian soldier i'm not even
kidding
and besides he points out they have
increasingly few options now
we have no other choice
but defend our city our capital and our
country
what is the other chair
we didn't invade anyone they came to our
home and killing our men women and
children
there's a deepening frustration amongst
ukrainians as time runs out for any
concrete outside help with soldiers
civilians and journalists being killed
and injured
this must be devastating for anyone who
comes from this area
what are you
what are your thoughts about how much
the international community is not just
devastating
this is war behind me building where
civilians were killed by the russian
rocket and this is not just the first
and not the last
it doesn't matter who you are on the
ukrainian soil now
with the press bench
a little girl a boy
an adult
man or woman
or an old person
you're a target
from russia from russian army
but so many of kiev's residents refuse
to be intimidated despite it all
come and have coffee with us she's
saying to our crew when will he be open
she takes barely a heartbeat to think
about this
[Music]
soon she says
even with the russian military closing
in on them their spirit seems
unbreakable
alex crawford sky news in kiev
well now the situation right across
ukraine and another attempt to send aid
into the besieged city of mariappol
appears to have been unsuccessful
however the city council says 2000 cars
were able to leave the city
russia says the entire kursan region is
now under their control forces are
believed to be preparing to advance on
odessa next ukraine's crucial economic
hub
more than 60 russian airstrikes hit
kharkiv last night and officials say
dinipro airport's runway was destroyed
in an attack to the west 19 people are
now confirmed dead following a strike on
a tv tower in the rivne region and the
red cross reports buses with civilians
on board have left the sumi region today
via humanitarian corridors well skies
alastair bunker is in la vie and joins
me now and alaska first of all a high
level uh political delegation heading to
the capital tonight
yeah the leaders of poland uh slovenia
and the czech republic
fellow eastern european states have
arrived in the capital kiev uh this
evening they arrived here by train uh
they've come here despite the capital
being under bombardment i'm speaking to
a ukrainian diplomat within the last few
minutes and she says that it is very
very noisy there at the moment but they
have come here in an active war zone
to show an act of solidarity to the
ukrainian president uh
zielinski and to make sure that they see
it for themselves and i think that is uh
something that we haven't seen from any
western leader for well i can't remember
the last time that a western leader went
to a war zone like this but it will
hopefully i imagine shape their
um view of what is going on here when
they can see and hear what's going on on
the ground and we'll see how that shapes
uh the eu's response to all this the
native secretary general as well
speaking today jen stoltenberg
warning about
russia's rhetoric around chemical and
biological weapons
russia has suggested that the united
states is funding various biological
labs across ukraine including three
around this city of la viv and
the fear is
that that is a false flag
or at least they're laying the ground
for a false flag operation
they are making absurd claims about
biological labs and chemical weapons in
ukraine
this is just another lie
and we are concerned
that moscow could stage
a false flag operation possibly
including chemical weapons
and aleister president zielenski making
some more comments about nato today of
course could have a bearing on the on
the peace discussions
yeah big time uh zalensky is saying that
ukraine has to accept that it's not
going to become a member of nato uh
anytime soon now
anyone who knows the nato membership
process will say that has been evident
for a long time despite what president
putin has said about the threat of
ukraine wanting to join nato the fact is
if you want to join the alliance you
cannot have any border or territorial
disputes which means what has been going
on the donbass region of the eight year
over the last eight years would have
prevented ukraine from joining nato
anyway uh zielenski has up till now
uh quite steadfastly maintained
ukraine's uh right joy nato if he wanted
to but he's kind of changed his tune and
we wonder whether that is part of the
negotiation part of the diplomatic
process that is going on behind the
scenes and whether it could form uh the
pillar of some sort of uh ceasefire deal
uh if he can try and convince the rest
of ukraine that joining nato is not the
build and end all will that
satisfy vladimir putin will that lead to
russian troops finally retreating from
the country aleister bunkel in lev thank
you very much
well now we have had hundreds of
questions about the war in ukraine and
the security and defense analyst michael
clark is here again with me to answer as
many of them as we can welcome back
michael good to see you let's dive
straight in because there are so many
people having so so many concerns and no
we start with anne's question there it
is and uh it's uh well pretty eternal
question about this war what will it
take if anything for nato to get
involved militarily with the crisis
because i suppose nato is already
involved just not directly absolutely
nato is already deeply in this crisis
it's supplying ukraine pretty obviously
and it's doing all it can to reinforce
its own borders and put pressure on the
russians and president putin what i
suspect and is getting at is will nato
troops go into ukraine to fight and what
i guess her question may think maybe
about is if putin used chemical weapons
would that be a threshold that we would
cross and i think the answer is no i
mean president putin at the moment is
trying to
goad nato into doing something so he can
say look nato is attacking me he's
trying to actually make nato overreact
and nato is being very careful to help
as much as it can in ukraine without
overreacting and making this crisis what
evidence have you noticed of that
goading was that attack near the border
with poland was that part of it well he
keeps threatening his uh nuclear forces
he's even threatening that there might
be a uh a a nuclear spillage um the
today uh a
russian drone went into polish territory
and came out again another russian drone
went into romanian territory came out
again carefully calculate these are
surveillance drones they weren't armed
but both of them invaded nato territory
for a short time and he's he's also made
it clear that he will attack
nato convoys or nato equipment once it's
over the ukrainian side of the border
the implication is he might even start
to attack when it's on the polish side
of the border which would be a huge
challenge to nato indeed and i suppose
this includes uh no fry zone which would
have to be enforced by nato aircraft
yeah putin could then go back to the
russian people and say see i told you so
nato is attacking russia yes he's been
saying publicly since 2008 that nato is
a threat to russia
and uh he's looking for evidence that he
can show to people that look i was right
look look what they're now doing so he's
trying to extend this war it's partly
the old hitlerian principle actually
that the way to recover from one huge
strategic blunder is to make another
somewhere else because that throws
everything up in the air and as the
cards land you try you think you might
get a better hand and the danger is that
president putin's in a real mess with
this war he might try to retrieve it by
making it into a bigger war so that he
can manipulate it in some way okay well
let's uh talk more about uh that nato
equipment that is being given in great
quantities to ukraine and uh this uh a
question from busta about the aircraft
or it was mentioned at the very start
of the war is there any way poland can
get the mig fighters to
the ukrainian air force now we know that
the polish have tried this but the
americans have rejected it yeah
i mean what poland did uh this time last
week is that they said we'll send our uh
mig-29s to ramstein which is the biggest
american base we'll give them to the
american germans in germany and then the
americans can give them to the
ukrainians and then the russians can
take it up with the americans the
americans didn't know about this it's
one of the few cases where nato was not
particularly united it's the only case
really so far and the americans
immediately backed off and the view is
that it would it would provoke the
russians to the point where it would
pull nato in so if if if nato aircraft
as it were were being flown by ukrainian
pilots in uh asp in ukrainian airspace
the russians again might take that as an
excuse to say you know we can take
action inside poland because you
actually supplied your aircraft to our
adversaries it's it's i wouldn't rule it
out as this crisis goes on but for the
time being nato is not going to have
mig-29s uh flying inside ukraine let's
examine the issue now of um as we hear
from nato itself rather than bhutan
getting less nato that's his ambition
he's going to get more nato and it's
encapsulated in this next question
coming up from bob there it is how
likely is it that finland would apply to
join nato and how would russia respond i
mean not just finland those um those
non-nato yeah countries countries like
like sweden and of course finland's
fought a bit like ukraine fought russia
on its own in the past then ussr
famously the winter war of 1939 40 where
they did incredibly well but ultimately
lost to russian numbers and finland has
pursued a very careful line ever since
1945 of being
neither aligned one way or the other
being careful about what russia thought
not provoking russia but being western
in every other respect
finland has never wanted seriously to
join nato in in 2017 53 percent of the
population who were polls said no we
don't want to join nato 2017. this year
two weeks ago 53 exactly the same number
saying now we do want to join nato now
this time there was a bigger number of
don't knows there's about 89 don't knows
but the fact is there's been a swing in
public opinion in finland to say
actually i think we do need to come into
nato at some point in the future and
finnish politicians are going out of
their way i mean one of the leaders of
the opposition was writing only today in
the financial times saying the time has
come for us to come off the fence
because russia is not just a threat to
us it's a threat to european security so
the chances of finland applying for nato
membership are now really quite high so
how do you like that mr putin yeah just
that broader point about more nato
whether more countries join or not the
fact is that whatever way this conflict
lands nato is going to reinforce that
eastern flank as much as it can over the
next months and yes
it may not last but europe has
rediscovered itself since the 24th of
february the eu has been far more
effective than anyone thought likely
nato has been far more united and
cohesive and tough than anyone thought
likely europe is a different animal this
this last three weeks the challenge will
be is will it still be a different
animal in six months time we'll see but
at the moment i think mr putin like most
of the rest of us to be honest have been
surprised by how strong the western
reaction has been and how quick and
effective it has been well you touched
there michael on the fact that putin
might try to expand this conflict so
let's bring in well what was unthinkable
it seems only a few weeks ago now it's
certainly not the uh issue of uh the
nuclear threats uh the chilling nuclear
threats made by russia and uh this one
carries says if russia does hit the
nuclear button
where are the like where are they likely
to target would they be would they
initially be on the on the battlefield
within ukraine so to speak or would be
would there be a first strike i think we
have to say dermot we are a long long
long way from this
but
uh presumably
in the pentagon throughout the that's
right
people worry about it
but the planning is going on is it lenin
famously said nothing happens for
decades then decades happen in days
that's where we are now so things are
happening very quickly but we're still a
long way from this now the russians have
a nuclear policy which integrates
nuclear weapons right down to the lowest
levels of their forces we we don't in
the west we keep our nuclear weapons
quite separate to our forces but the
russians use them on the battlefield or
they train to at least so that if if
there were a nuclear use it is
overwhelmingly likely if it were to
happen that it would be on the
battlefield somewhere
it's plausible if we're in this crazy
world that it might be on the
battlefields of ukraine or it might be
over the border in poland or romania
which would be a which would be an
article 5 triggering of nato and then
we're into really seriously i mean just
this on the battlefield i mean it's a
glib phrase but there isn't actually a
battlefield in ukraine we're not seeing
you know mass armies of tanks fighting
each other it's a
it's a very complex war it is in fields
and bushes and forests that's right i
mean and the you know
russian nuclear weapons were designed as
battlefield weapons for russian armies
that were moving forward in a more
conventional way in western europe and
also to deter western forces from using
our
slightly bigger and more developed
nuclear forces which are there's a big
gap between our conventional and nuclear
in russia there's no gap
if russia were to use the its strategic
nuclear forces its rockets and submarine
launch weapons then
you're talking about wholesale nuclear
war and again we are a long long long
way from that well where are they likely
to talk about you know the question then
encapsulates would they be likely to to
strike a major city from one of their
now adversaries in in nato one of the
capitals well that would be a trigger
for
the closest the world has ever come to
an to a straight nuclear war okay
well uh let's uh follow on from that and
you you touched on it again there
michael about the chain of command i
mean you can tell us about how it works
um in our country in the united states
as well how does the chain of command
work for putin to authorize a nuclear
attack who else would need to be
involved and support this within russia
i suppose natasha is asking can he more
or less do it himself you know actually
is there a button on the desk yeah
natasha asks a very good question
there's two uh lines if we were talking
about battlefield nuclear weapons
because they're at low levels with uh
with ground forces then the chain of
command is quite a long one so it's from
putin to the general staff down to the
nuclear control uh centers down to the
low levels of field commanders so quite
a lot of people have actually got to be
involved in it
and on past experience i think that
those orders if he gave them wouldn't be
obeyed
in in terms of tactical nuclear weapons
however it just just expanded that past
experience well uh in abel abel archer
was a famous kid in 1983 there was a it
was a big mistake uh the western
alliance gave the russians the
impression because of a technical glitch
that an attack was building the russians
took it really seriously and they
started to arm all their nuclear weapons
because they were so anxious this was
october 83 and a a colonel lieutenant
colonel stanislav petrov disobeyed
orders he said i don't believe it i
don't believe it and he delayed he
delayed long enough for them to find out
that it was all a technical error and
there was a critical 40 minutes when
petrov said i don't believe it i am
disobeying orders he was the man who
should have actually given the alert and
if they had a colonel he was slow down
he was a colonel if they had on the
nuclear weapons that's detected then by
the united states and others and who
knows what happened we came very close
to an accidental exchange of some sort
in october 1983. and you think that i
mean it would rely on that if putin gave
the fighter now you think there are
imposed within the russian hierarchy
chain of command because this this is
not a nuclear crisis this is a crisis
about something else cuba in 1962 was a
nuclear crisis it was about nuclear
weapons and there was a lot of of
tension in the nuclear force on both
sides but this isn't so i don't think i
don't think his orders would be obeyed
i'm just guessing obviously but there is
another element here which i think
natasha may be thinking about is that if
putin gave orders to his submarine
commanders if he were ever to launch a
strategic nuclear attack on the west
using his nuclear weapons submarines
which are out in the atlantic most the
time or some of the time
um that order goes straight from the
president to the submarine commander
doesn't pass through anybody else
so in that case
there might be a bigger case for saying
maybe his orders will be carried out
would rather depend on the submarine
commander
i think on that now michael we need to
take a break to draw a breath and absorb
all that you're watching the sky news
question and answer special on the war
in ukraine
as the russian journalist who
interrupted a state tv news program last
night is fine for her protest against
the war we'll answer your questions
about how the conflict is being reported
in russia
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back now marina oceanic cover
the russian television news producer who
states an extraordinary anti-war protest
live on national television last night
has appeared in a court in moscow her
act of defiance during a prime time news
bulletin came at great risk to her
personal freedom under russia's new
censorship laws the kremlin said her
actions amounted to an act of
hooliganism and she was fined about 200
pounds or 30 000 rubles this report from
our moscow correspondent diana magnay
contains some flash photography
this was an astonishing act of courage
five seconds on state tv that millions
will have watched don't believe the
propaganda they are lying
a relatively small fine but there may be
more to come
[Music]
we asked the man often called russia's
chief propagandist the head of media
empire russia syvonya what he thought of
it
here
ukraine is more united than it has ever
been and there are people in their
basements with the bombs falling on them
calling their parents in russia and
their parents don't believe them because
it's not shown on state tv
what do you make of that
absolutely
um
two other russian state tv journalists
announced their resignations today one
of them a long-time presenter who'd left
the country a few days ago and the other
a foreign correspondent who was already
based in europe because if you oppose
what russia is doing it is safer to be
outside the country than in
protesting inside russia tends not to
end up well
this woman is holding up a sign which
literally says just two words
enough to see her taken in
and then this woman too who was
explaining how she opposed the protests
15 000 people detained since putin moved
into ukraine
in such circumstances like we have
nowadays
it's really difficult to
be
completely free and do whatever you want
unfortunately i think we need peace
of course
it's my own position
that is a position shared across the
world just not perhaps by the one man
who could make it happen
dinah magney sky news moscow
well in that battle to get the truth out
ukraine's president zielenski has been
using some of his video messages to
directly address the russian people
speaking last night he thanked the woman
who interrupted that russian tv
broadcast and encouraged all russians to
dissent against the invasion now this is
some of what he said
you will take lives there are a lot of
you but your life will also be taken
but why should you die
i know that you want to survive we
intercept your conversations we hear
what you really think about this
senseless war about this disgrace and
about your state
president zielenski there well let's
examine now then the potential for
disquiet about the water spread within
russia itself with our defense and
security analyst michael clark once
again and uh we're obviously going to
put your questions to him about that
plenty of them uh as you can see this
from andrew two parts to this i suppose
andrew asks how likely are we to see an
uprising of the russian people against
the kremlin as sanctions take hold of
the country and they start to see
through the propaganda that they're
being subjected to through the russian
media well uh let's talk michael in
first of all about that that top part
how likely to see an uprising in russia
against the kremlin against putin
particularly with the the economic pain
that russia's been subjected to i mean
the economic pain is certainly having an
effect as of i think last night 375
western firms have pulled out of russia
and so people notice
um about a million people have been made
unemployed in the last three or four
days because those firms are pulled out
so this is beginning to have an impact
on the other hand
um putin is not that unpopular with
ordinary russians particularly outside
the cities because they think he's
restored russia he's got over some of
the humiliations they felt in the 1990s
and there is actually and they blame the
west they blame the west for their
problems as if they're being blamed and
sanctions are really unjust
um there's no mechanism for any sort of
popular uprising if there is to be some
movement against putin which i believe
there will be it won't come from from
the majority of people it will come from
the elites and the cities who see more
easily what is going on it'll come from
the security services and the military
who are being blamed at the moment for
what's gone wrong i mean already quite a
lot of fsb senior officers appear to
have been arrested that's the old kgb
the svr which is the equivalent of mi6
are being blamed the gru which is
military intelligence are really being
blamed and the military had been blamed
for not being better so the three big
security services and the military and
the some of the oligarchs some of the
kleptocrats and some of the elites in
the cities that's the group from which
some revolt against putin if it arises
is likely to arise not from a popular
uprising i think so from within the
institutions that are not that different
really from the way the soviet union
used to operate the removal of
khrushchev and and things like that that
then the big question is
what character of person do you get do
we get a democrat a proper democrat or
do we get putin plus no well we probably
get putin minus um because by but
whenever this happens and you know i've
been saying i mean this could happen in
in three months or it could happen in
three years but it will happen
and what we'll get is is a russia that's
on its knees in some way when that does
happen economically much poorer and so
although we will get some sort of putin
clone of some sort it won't be a won't
be a democrat um
it may be a putin clone who realizes
that they've got to change and they've
got somehow to get back on tour and how
does the west have to react then to this
new leader whenever it happens
very generously sanctions removed
unconditionally on condition
so and the west has got to start
thinking now this is this is a time for
all great strategists to come to the
party the west has got to start thinking
now what sort of russia do we want to
live with in 10 and 20 years time so
let's think about that and then design a
policy back from there as to what we're
going to do when putin disappears which
as i say might be quite soon might be in
a while um and russia will be will be
enfeebled to a fairly big extent when
that happens so how do we organize our
policy to get the the result we want in
10 or 20 years okay yeah plenty more
questions to come michael do stay with
us sir you're watching a sky news
question and answer special on the war
in ukraine and we'll be going through
your questions about russia's military
campaign next with our security and
defense analyst professor michael clark
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to this sky news special on
the war in ukraine our defense and
security analyst michael clark is here
with me to take a look at the questions
now on the military strategies of russia
and ukraine so we start with this
question from howard what are the key
cities michael that russia needs to take
to fulfill its military ambitions and
how do you rate their chances and what
does it tell us about the russian
strategy yeah well the russian strategy
to begin with was to take the whole of
ukraine uh in effect within three days
and mop up by the 8th of march and here
we are on 15th of march and they haven't
even reached square one yet so the
original strategy was to take all the
cities that's clearly impossible
the fallback strategy might be might be
to actually take the cities that are
east of the nipra so those are the
cities that they're fighting in at the
moment like chernihev and sumi and
kharkiv and so on right down the coast
to mariopol
and create a even annex them to the to
russia and then create a puppet state to
the west of the nepa based on lev uh cut
it off from the sea by taking odessa and
so have as it were an extension of
russian territory east of the nepa and a
puppet state like belarus west of the
nebras that's possible
but in my view they still can't do it
because you simply i mean even east of
the nipple that's 15 million people you
can't hold down that number of people
with the number of troops the russians
have got you can't and how important is
kiev to the strategy taking gear they
would have to occupy here yeah they
can't leave kiev out of it and kiev
certainly can't be this couldn't be the
the capital of a rump ukraine it would
have to be la viv or somewhere that's
not gear that's the point because kiev
is so much more important than moscow in
slavic history kiev was founded in the
year 482. it's 1500 years old it's it's
it's it's 700 years older than moscow so
you can't have kiev as in a rump state
because that would be the real ukraine
but can you destroy kiev
in that analysis
while you're doing it well you you could
lay it flat the city of domes um one of
the jewels in the crown of slavic
civilization see the russians reduce
that to ashes would be
appalling and i don't think
not putin would never get over i don't
think russia would ever recover from
that to be honest and it's the ukrainian
strategy the flip side of that then just
defend these major cities fight them to
a standstill you're not going to destroy
the russian army outright but you can
just hold them where they are correct i
mean the ukrainians don't have enough to
beat the russian army in any in any
obvious sense they can't split them in
half they can't encircle them they can't
throw them out of the country but they
can fight them to a standstill which is
what they're doing in three in three
places i i mean on the road to odessa in
this north south link up they're trying
to create and rank kiev now they can
suffer an awful lot when they do they
might crack informed units but then
they'll they'll blend into the
territorial units 25 brigades one in
each region and they'll fight and fight
and fight that seems to be the case and
so they can fight the russians to stand
still and win politically let's talk
about uh
reinforcements and uh we've been hearing
haven't we about um the russians
bringing in more forces and this from
mike could the introduction of chechen
and syrian fighters in large numbers
overwhelmed the resistance well we know
the chechens are already there and
there's talk of bringing in uh syrian
fighters who are experts in urban
warfare yeah that changed the dynamic it
won't have a huge strategic effect it
will increase the nastiness of the whole
thing though some of these people are
very not at all very nice people they
you know belong to ultra groups of
various sorts they're they're
experienced fighters but you know it's
an inconvenient factor that the
ukrainians have got some very unpleasant
people on their side there's the azov
brigade who are defending mario paul for
ruthlessly at the moment that's a crowd
of neo-nazi white separatists sorry
white supremacists and there's a the
number one dunipro brigade very similar
i mean there are some there are some
very unpleasant groups in ukraine that
were in ukraine they do have a
right-wing problem
and they are not examplified that
exactly
it's a propaganda win for putin because
he says look we're fighting these other
people these as a brigade look at them
and it's true it's an inconvenient fact
but
in war you know my enemies enemy is my
friend they are they're all ukrainians
now as and when this war goes somewhere
you know whatever happens to ukraine
they're going to have to deal with these
somewhat unpleasant groups it always
happens it all happens in the second
world war all the time you know
communists um and right-wing fascists
actually got together to oppose the
germans and when the war came to an end
then they started fighting each other
that's a that's an argument for tomorrow
but it is it is an unpleasant fact that
they're just as the syrians and chechens
are coming into this war so there are
some really one or two
unpleasant neo-nazi groups fighting for
the ukrainians okay yeah we're talking
about uh physical reinforcements there
for the russians so let's talk now with
this question about um
getting financial and military
assistance this from stephen given the
recent reports of putin's approach to
china for financial and military
assistance what action in the event this
assistance is provided could the west
take in response which turns the
spotlight on china how to deter them yes
i mean the americans are already saying
very loudly in public and in private to
the chinese don't do this you know don't
get yourself involved with um saving
putin um be careful because if you do we
really will sanction you and you've seen
now in the last three weeks how powerful
western sanctions really can be i mean
nobody thought western sanctions would
be this powerful but they are um and so
that's what the americans are saying now
the chinese are having to think very
carefully at the moment because um they
they already last week sorry earlier
this week uh they um
denied aircraft parts to russia
observing american sanctions and so they
linked him with that policy at the same
time they defend russia in the u.n they
recycle these stupid russian stories
about biological and chemical weapons
plants in ukraine which is pure rubbish
but the chinese media recycles them
xi jinping is on the fence at the moment
he's pursuing a policy of what i call
friendly neutrality he's he's staying
neutral but his neutrality helps putin
because he's protecting him
he he doesn't have months to work this
out he's only got weeks to work it out
usually when leaders have to take these
big geopolitical decisions they have
years or at least months to make them
he's got about two weeks before things
in ukraine reach a really critical stage
and he's got to decide is he going to
back putin and back all that's going to
involve be complicit in these barbaric
attacks
um and do himself quite a lot of harm or
is he actually going to emerge as the
peacemaker the statesman of the world
who is the one person who could stop
this war because if xi jinping
says to putin it's over then it probably
okay we're going to address that uh
issue uh more deeply a little bit later
on let's ask more about the conflict
though and um
what are the chances that russia might
attack nearby countries not in nato such
as moldova that from you are now uh
molded over there kind of sandwiched uh
between ukraine and the european union
uh we know that it's it's on putin's
list so to speak well it may be it's
only 30 miles west of odessa and so if
the russians get to odessa which will be
quite a quite an if at the moment but if
they get to odessa then the temptation
will be to go another 30 miles because
just over the border in moldova is
transnistria which is a self-declared
russian republic it's still based on the
old red the red army the 14th army in
the old red army and so a lot of very
determined russians live there and they
they've basically declared independence
they have their own currency they have
plastic coins because they can't afford
they can't afford real coins so they
have plastic money but you know it works
and so you've got this group who are
like a mini donbass a mini separatist
and the that and there's a thousand
russian troops there i mean we think
there's more than a thousand but
officially there's a thousand russian
troops plus a lot of separatists in
transnistria in moldova the general view
is if the russians moved against moldova
moldova would actually fall apart quite
quickly because it's a it's a poor state
and it's a small state and it's
ethnically more or less
romanian actually but um that's would
certainly be at risk but so with the
baltics the if if we're right and i hope
we're not but if we're right that mr
putin is trying to make this war more
general to actually make it bigger
because he's trying to retrieve the
blunder of making the war in the first
place
then the baltics are are vulnerable
estonia latvia lithuania
and the possibility there's a piece of
russia in lithuania on the baltic coast
right kaliningrad it's a piece of russia
detached from the rest of russia and
there's an area called the savalki
corridor or the svalky gap about about
40 50 miles long 30 miles wide which
which would join lithuania and belarus
and cut the baltics off from road uh
reinforcement so that the baltics could
only be reinforced by nature by air or
by sea in the baltics so watch out for
that um last question on this section it
concerning uh belarus and this is about
the reinforcements so as we know they're
taking these terrible losses the
russians how likely is it that the
belarusian military will enter the war
what might the likely impact be if they
do and uh there's president lukashenko
of uh belarus we know he's been he's
been he's been summoned in the past for
talks with putin in moscow hasn't he
yeah look at schenker he's been doing a
sort of diplomatic okie cookie i mean
first of all he was he was absolutely in
and he was he was making it very clear
to his people that uh we are we're all
part of this this is great when it went
wrong you don't he was out and so he
then tried to reassure everyone in
belarus that belarusian troops are not
involved even if belarusian territory is
involved in some of the air defense
which the russians are using so then
they're out now he's under great
pressure to go back in again and we know
from intelligence reports which have
been shared a lot of belarusian soldiers
are deserting because they're actually
being lined up to cross the border and
all these armies they lose people like
there's no tomorrow when they think
they're going into battle so the
belarusians may be
forced to to go across the border
because the russians are seriously
running short of troops to get this next
phase of their battle completed where
they just need to overwhelm the
ukrainian forces until they crack as
formed units that's the next phase for
them whether they will or not i don't
know but they're now they've they've
committed all 190 000 that they prepared
for this and they're now short of troops
keep an eye on the belarusians okay
michael thank you very much indeed for
this uh section you're watching the sky
news question and answer special on the
war in ukraine next how might the
conflict in ukraine draw to a conclusion
we'll be talking what the possible end
game of the war in ukraine could look
like with michael sharp
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they have breached the road there is
a lot of gas being fired all around us
[Music]
it is an absolute carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modern despite the victory
these students
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
i'm never lazarus and i'm skies reporter
based in delhi
welcome back to our question and answer
special on ukraine now in the time we've
got left let's take a look at how the
war in ukraine might end uh with our
defense and security analyst professor
michael clark got a question from
stewart says how long can russia sustain
its military campaign
financially and i suppose that takes in
the loss of men and equipment as well
yes i mean in terms of direct costs it's
more or less self-financing this war
because the of the increase in uh energy
prices so it's
most analysts say it's costing them
about a billion dollars a day to run
this wall but they're taking in almost a
billion dollars a day in energy income
so the war itself and they'll take in
more as energy prices go higher so
direct costs not such a big problem for
them but the indirect cost costs are
huge because it looks as if the russian
economy is going to shrink by between 12
and 15 percent as a result of this war
and that's a great deal more than it
shrank by in the 1998 financial crisis
sorry 2008 financial crisis or the kovic
crisis but we hear talk of russia
defaulting on some of its loans
as soon as the middle of this week
that's right they're about to default
but what they're actually going to do
they're going to pay their interest in
rubles which nobody wants now
technically they're allowed to do that
but in financially nobody will take it
seriously so it means that they're
they're they've been downgraded to junk
status so all of their bonds are junk
status now s ps and and um uh all of the
uh ratings agencies standards and poor's
uh standard poor they've they've just
downgraded all their bonds yeah well
okay well we're talking about how this
war might end uh let's look at uh this
route which is the the preferred russian
route we know from from day one of this
war rosie asks what would happen if
president zielinski were killed by the
russian army or by russian irregulars by
chechens we understand uh launched some
assassination attempts according to
president zielinski in the first few
weeks i mean what would happen if the
russians as they want to do took him out
for sure i mean if the russians got hold
of zelinski they will kill him for sure
they won't let him survive because he'll
be a figurehead and so on however um the
ukrainians on western advice some time
ago created a very long succession list
now we don't know who's on that list but
one assumes that the prime minister is
and probably the defense minister so
if if zelensky were killed then that
immediately there would be a new leader
whether that person would become the
president or just be the prime minister
defenseman
whatever it is but they have a long
succession list and i have to say i mean
three weeks ago i thought that mr
zolensky would be lucky to stay alive
for the next couple of weeks when we
thought the russians will be able to
take kiev quite quickly um the situation
the war now is i think he's got a better
than even's chance of being there when
putin falls
well let's uh look lastly then that's uh
what everyone's hoping for the some kind
of diplomatic solution to the crisis and
that's the question from
sauron there how likely is a diplomatic
solution to the crisis so our picture
there shows the presidents um biden and
putin but i think as we touched on
earlier in this hour michael perhaps xi
jinping should be in there as well for
sure he's the one person who could as it
would create the impetus for a
diplomatic solution and the ukrainians
of course there are you know there are
hiding to nothing in one sense i mean
golda meir the israeli prime minister in
67 she said you can't negotiate with
somebody trying to kill you which is
what this started as however if the
russians are looking for a way out of
some sort then there may be some sort of
negotiation and the point about the
ukrainians is that they won't want to
negotiate for their own removal as a
state
but they can keep negotiations going
maybe for some months so they live to
fight another day
and
in this sort of situation when things
are happening so quickly if you can buy
a ceasefire that lasts a few months then
you do live to fight another day and
what the ukrainians are saying is look
you know we're negotiating but we're
still fighting so he said they say we'll
talk as if we are not fighting and we
will fight as if we're not talking but
if we get to that how do we the west how
do we deal with putin after this how do
we trust anything he says anything he
signs we don't we we have to say to
putin look this has been a huge
strategic mistake
you or people around you've got to
realize this we will help you get out of
it we'll help you you know go out of
this situation climb down but nothing
will be the same again mr putin you
cannot go back to zero from before the
24th of february so everything is
different now and if you prepare to
withdraw from ukraine and we'll maybe
discuss something on the base of the
austrian state treaty of 1955 which is a
treaty of neutrality which the soviet
union accepted for austria might be
might be a model that we could talk
about ukrainians say they won't but i
bet they would if it created a ceasefire
so let's think of some devices to help
you climb down but don't believe mr
putin that you can never get back where
you were in world politics before this
war started professor michael clark
thank you so so much what a productive
and insightful hour we have had and uh
thank you for answering uh so many of
those questions and thank you to
everyone who sent those questions in on
the war in ukraine for this sky news
special now coming up in the next hour
a curfew has been imposed on ukraine's
capital kiev until thursday uh as the
mayor of the city has warned of
difficult hours to come
[Music]
you